hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast advanced sensitivity and
resolution in flow cytometry through
innovation I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labret and sponsored by
Beckman Coulter life sciences beckman
coulter develops manufactures and
markets products that simplify automate
and innovate complex biomedical testing
more than 25,000 to I'm sorry more than
275,000 Bethan culture systems operate
in both diagnostics and life science
laboratories on seven continents for
more than 80 years the company's
products have been making a difference
in people's lives by improving the
productivity of medical professionals
and scientists supplying critical
information for improving patient health
and delivering trusted solutions for
research and discovery for more
information please visit beckman coulter
calm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
when we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions like typing them in the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
carrying this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Jay Paul
Robinson Jay Paul Robinson is the svm
professor of sight onyx and ecology
veteran veterinary medicine and a
professor of biomedical engineering in
the welding school of biomedical
engineering at Purdue University he
received his PhD in immuno pathology
from the University of New South Wales
in Sydney Australia he has given a large
number of talks and presentations to
student groups and community service
organizations is also the Immediate Past
Chair of the Purdue universe
the Senate his research area has been
focused on reactive oxygen species
primarily in neutrophils and cell lines
such as hl-60 cells his lab is currently
focused on mitochondrial function I will
now turn it over to dr. Jay Paul
Robinson for his presentation well good
morning everyone and thank you Judy for
that generous introduction I was asked
by colleagues at beckman coulter to talk
a little bit about the nature of the
side effects instrument and why this
instrument is a little bit different and
if you look at the vast majority of
instruments that are out there for flow
cytometry they all do a pretty good job
in general flow cytometry is at a very
high standard and we are very glad that
so many companies are building really
extra extra extra high quality insurance
so i would say that there are four
essential feature differences in the
side effects than other instruments and
what i propose to do in this webinar is
to really focus on those differences to
try to explain why they're different and
what advantages or they may have so the
detectors they're different the light
managing technology is also different
the fluidics are different and it also
has multiple software side side scatter
options so I'm going to talk about those
features the question that one might ask
is why do we care in terms of detectors
one hundred percent of other flow
cytometers use photomultiplier tubes why
do we care if an instrument doesn't use
photomultiplier tubes
because photomultiplier tubes have been
used for 40 years and they have some
some great advantages and they're
certainly extremely good at doing what
they do so one might argue that it's a
good idea to stay with something that
works that's certainly a philosophy that
many people might have if we look at
light manipulation the traditional
dichroic and bandpass system that almost
all flow cytometers use works very well
also fiber optics work well so why would
we change something that's so
fundamental I'll try to answer that
question what about fluidics most flow
said a lot of flow cytometers maybe not
most use a positive pressure system that
works very well it may not be so
quantitative but that is not really
considered a major disadvantage there
really are no major negatives about the
way current systems work so again you
have to ask yourself the question why
would you change a system if things work
well and finally in terms of side
scatter I would say that greater
majority of instruments probably take
their sights get a signal off the blue
laser the foreign 488 laser on most
systems and the this works very well for
blood samples for cell lines and for
reasonable sized particles and so maybe
there are some advantages to looking at
alternatives for for smaller particles
so as I pointed out the side effects
instrument changes a few things the
detectors are not standard the optics I
would say is not standard the fluidics
is not standard and there are
combinations of lasers which I think are
probably available on on most
potentially on most instruments but
there are some slight differences in in
how the site of Lexi does this so let's
take a look now at each of these systems
and I'll first of all focus on the
detectors so why did I say that the side
effects is a little different as you see
on the left side I put a couple of
pictures up of photomultiplier tubes the
the one with the glass case is pretty
nice because it really shows you what's
going on inside the photomultiplier tube
we we probably don't use those in in any
current flow cytometers but the
principle of the photomultiplier is well
known and works very well and there have
been lots of developments in flow
cytometers over the years and on the
right side is let's say a law compact
version one that's probably pretty
standard on most flow cytometers so this
is what we have on air flow cytometers
and the reason is because
photomultiplier tubes are very reliable
very sensitive and they work very well
if you look on the right hand side
you'll see this tiny little device there
it looks a bit like a tin can and that's
an avalanche photodiode and so what
happens in the side effects is that we
don't have in photomultiplier tubes we
only have avalanche photodiodes so
what's the big deal about avalanche
photodiodes well there are a number of
issues and I'm not going to go into a
great deal of technical issue in in this
webinar but I have prepared some other
materials that will be made available
shortly that will give much more detail
on each of the things that I'm talking
about today
but a pds are incredibly efficient and
if you remember what quantum efficiency
is it's it's basically the number of
electrons emitted divided by the number
of incident photons so this is around
about eighty percent for a PDS compared
to about twenty-five percent for pmts
and so traditionally we've avoided using
a PDS for a number of fairly good
reasons but APD's do something very
similar to what PMT's do in that they
amplify a signal and as I said I'm not
going to discuss the process where how
that amplification occurs but if you
think in general terms of what an
avalanche is and if you see up there on
the top right hand corner this is our
murder blom which has a huge block of
snow up there which you have to climb
over if you're going to get to the
summit and I can tell you from personal
experience of being in these places that
an avalanche is pretty nasty once that
Avalanche that's just from a very small
signal just kicking a little bit of snow
you can have an avalanche that has
hundreds and thousands tens of thousands
of tons and in fact that is what happens
in an avalanche photodiode so the term
avalanche is really very appropriate
there when you think in terms of of what
is actually happening in in the
Avalanche photo diet so we do have this
ability to take a very small signal and
amplify the other advantage of a pds is
that depending on the type of APD you
use you can get a very broad
range of wavelengths selectivity and
it's actually much broader than
photomultiplier tubes while the multiple
tubes have a problem above about 750 800
nanometers but avalanche photodiodes are
very sensitive above that range so it is
possible actually to design systems that
cover a very broad range so that's a
reason for considering APD's and a new
generation of a PDS has been developed
and these APD's are very very high
quality if you can reduce the noise of
the APD's if you can increase the
efficiency of the connection of the
signal to the APD itself and if you have
very clean electronics it is possible to
use an APD and so a little later on I'm
going to talk a little bit more about a
PDS and how they're embedded into the
site a flex system and why they work so
well so the other thing that is quite
different in the side effects is the
detection optics now if you look at the
top of the site a flex system that I'm
now looking down on top of the
instrument you can see in the center
there's a silver box and that silver box
has a cover over it and death that are
three fibers and you can see them
popping out at the top there and going
to each of these purple blue and red
circles what's actually happening
underneath there is that there are on
some instruments 3a by trifa cated fiber
or one with four fibers coming out and
those fibers
that cover is really there just to
protect those fighters there's nothing
secret inside that box it's just a
protection for the fibers and those
fibers are now going to these places
where the optics is managed in the the
side effects now I want to talk a little
bit about what this process is what we
call wavelength division multiplexing
and this is one of the keys to the
success of why the side effects is is so
efficient and why I've been really
impressed with how this system works and
I'm I don't suppose a lot of you know
what wavelength division multiplexing is
but every single one of you is probably
using it on a daily basis and don't
really know it this technology was
really developed by in the
telecommunications industry quite a
number of years ago a couple of decades
ago and the the goal that was going from
the days when a telephone had a single
line to a switchboard and then a single
line to someone else's phone that's a
very inefficient technology and the idea
was can you put more signals over a
telephone line and that's how wavelength
division multiplexing developed now over
the years this has been enhanced
tremendously and so it shouldn't
surprise you to know that when you pick
up your cell phone and you you make make
a call you're obviously not connected to
any wires I've sort of shown a wire
there but it's a sort of virtual wire
but when you make that call you are
talking to some kind of tower and that
tell is receiving your cell phone
message and then that tower is either
communicating with another tower by
radio frequency or a micro
ish or it's very frequently
communicating with a fiber optic and
down those fiber optics the goal is
instead of having one cell phone message
to go through its to have many of them I
don't know whether any of you have ever
experienced dialing a number and getting
the wrong number or actually talking to
someone and having any interference on
the line but it is possible in in the
phone system to get some confusion but
it's a very rare event because
wavelength division multiplexing uses
very sophisticated technologies to
separate the frequencies of each phone
call and it uses a transponder sometimes
we use the term mux there but it's a
transponder that takes those signals
converts them into a mixed signal and
then goes through fiber optic comes out
the other end to another transponder
which now separates them back to those
original signals so that's how a cell
phone works so if we look at what's
actually happening from a light
management perspective in in a flow
cytometer in in fact in the site
oaklands you'll see that what I've shown
up here are just a bunch of colors
indicating different wavelengths perhaps
of fluorochromes and they're going to a
little box instead of calling it a
transponder I've used the term MUX and
then they travel in this case on a fiber
optic and they go to a place where there
d machst or another transponder and
their then returned to their original
wavelengths and so the question is how
does the side effects do this so I'm
going to show you some details of
actually what happens inside the side
effects
also drawn a diagram here you can see on
the bottom left there's input light
let's say this is the fiber optic it's
coming through and it's hitting a mirror
and that mirror is bouncing all the
signal back to another mirror now I've
drawn multiple mirrors on the back here
but you can imagine that that's just one
single mirror but it can also be
multiple mirrors it depends on how
complicated you want to make this device
you can see that the signal then is
bouncing out and there's a band pass
filter there and I just put and some
numbers on those you'll see this one
says for 2454 8520 and all I've
indicated there is that some of this
signal is going to go through a band
pass filter and that that band pass
filter is going to restrict what is
being sent here and these are going to
the detectives in normal flow cytometer
this would be a photomultiplier tube and
in the side effects this is going to be
an APD so this is a block inside the
side effects and I'll show you what that
looks like in a moment but this is the
principal so this is really a reflection
it's a mirror it's reflecting everything
what that means is that it's rather
efficient that it's not blocking any
signals all of the light is traveling as
far as it can and the appropriate light
is that you want to select is going
through this band pass filter and I'll
show you in a moment how you can just
drop in a different band pass filter in
there so let me show you this again in a
slightly different form so you can see
on here on the top right that there's a
an optical fiber it's going through a
lens and it's hitting
a mirror on this side and some of the
signal is going through to an APD that
says f APD just a fluorescence detector
and then some of that the rest of that
signal what what doesn't go through is
bounced onto a lira and then some of
that goes to another detector and you
can see that it's bouncing around and
around and around so that's the
fundamental technology that's inside the
side effects so let's look at one of
those WDM blocks so on the bottom of
this you see the actual block block
excuse me and at the bottom of that you
see a blue arrow I'm just indicating in
this one that the blue laser right is
coming into this block and inside the
middle of that block if you notice there
are some some smaller blocks that have
colors on them those are actually
holders and on the bottom of those
holders there's a really tiny band pass
filter that band pass filters only a few
millimeters wide and a few millimeters
long so it's extremely small and so you
can see in this this very small area
term maybe hmm 40 50 60 millimeters to
inches across that there are about six
different band pass filters in here and
just above it you'll see a diagrammatic
representation of the same thing so
you'll see some up above the band pass
filters going through to some detectives
so this is one what I will call a
wavelength division multiplexing later
now that's one time but the sikaflex
actually has two types and I just want
to show you this in our own I will
in this issue up again in a little while
when I talk about the different lasers
in and how those laser combinations can
be controlled and manipulated within
this on the right hand block you'll see
at the bottom there are two arrows and
that is representing two fiber optics
that are coming into this block now on
this particular one there's actually
only one but I'm diagrammatically
showing you that too could come into
this but above you'll see that there's a
small bar in the center of the circle I
don't know whether you can see my mouse
but I'm actually pointing to the middle
of the right-hand circle there's a
little bar there what's actually
happening here is that that mirror is
split into two and so there are now
three APD's on either side of that
mirror and one fiber optic is serving
one side and a different fiber optic is
serving the other side and as I said
I'll come back to that later because
this is a one of the fundamental amazing
advantages that I see in in this
instrument because it gives you an
almost unlimited number of combinations
that you can manipulate with just a very
very simple process so let's well i will
show you one more thing thats related to
that and this is the same diagram that i
showed before well almost the same
diagram but I've made a slight
difference in this diagram you'll see at
the top there's a single fiber optic
coming into it but in fact this is where
the split is that I was showing you so
I've just drawn a black line there it
sort of hmm let's say creates two
separate mirrors instead of this mirror
being one piece it's now two piece and
is blocked and
so now i can bring a second fiber into
this system so you can see the blue
fiber blue laser is coming from this one
the red laser is coming from this one
and on the left hand side you see the
number three that implies that i now
have three APD's three detectives that
are coming from this laser and three
detectives coming from this laser so
that that looks like this works in as
2wd IM modules okay so as i said i'll
come back to why that's important a
little bit later so the model there is
that it's a very it's very efficient
optical path way it's certainly i think
the most compact system that I've ever
seen it requires an extremely small
amount of physical space and the
distance from the actual detection of
the particles to the detector is
extremely small and these bandpass
filters are really really very very
small um and the fact that you can stick
any band pass filter into any way wdl
module i think is is is pretty nice
there's a virtually an unlimited number
of combinations depending on which laser
that you select so I've discussed the
fundamental differences in detectors the
fundamental differences in the optical
system and now I want to talk a little
bit about the differences that this
system has in in fluid x
so it's really not complicated at all it
again may well be one of the simplest
fluidic systems that I've seen there are
a couple of flow cytometers that have
extremely simple fluidic systems and the
site of lexus is definitely one of them
um I've put a circle around this device
in the middle this is a peristaltic pump
and this is the way that the sheath
fluid is manipulated now I I think that
the most reasonable question that you
could ask about using a peristaltic pump
is well don't we know that peristaltic
pumps operate by rotating a bar around a
tube and that creates pulsations and I
don't think there's anyone in the field
of flow cytometry that would be happy
with pulsations going through the flow
chamber and and so it's a very
reasonable Christian just at how do
dampen any potential pulsation now I'm
not going to discuss the details of how
this particular pump is designed but I
can say that the way it's designed is a
very clever technique to essentially
remove pulsations from the fluid that is
going through to the float chamber so um
that saves us from dealing with having
to struggle with a potential
pulsation problem and from my experience
that this this works very well now the
other question is can you get stable
flow it's a very reasonable question to
ask and we know that in traditional flow
cytometers where we use positive
pressure systems we have very
sophisticated pressure and fluidic
control if you just take a look at any
of the let's say traditional flow
cytometers that are on the market from
from every company you'll see how
complicated the pressure system and the
control system is for maintaining that
absolute pressure control in in the
sample delivery system so that the
hydrodynamic focusing is absolutely
stable and that there's no change in the
flow rate unless you change the system
yourself so this table this histogram
that I'm showing here shows the same
thing it's very hard to see but this is
a plot of fluorescence versus time and
I've drawn a line across the screen the
black line is a straight line that I
drew and the red line is the change in a
sample number or fluorescence intensity
in this case of particles going through
the system and so you know it's pretty
clear that this is a very very stable
flow system now this raises an
interesting question and I I can't
resist a little bit of Education on this
issue because it always concerns me that
when I'm talking to pee
or about flow cytometry and quality
control I just don't hear something that
I should be fundamental on every single
instrument every single sample that's
run on a flow cytometer should be
collecting time as a parameter there's
absolutely no excuse for people not to
have time as a parameter on every single
sample that's run and the reason is this
has been known for 30 years Jim Watson
for those of you who don't remember Jim
Jim is past president of Isaac and a
person of hers a very high reputation in
the field of flow cytometry for many
years and the minion in 1987 Jim
published this paper that you can see
here time a quality control perimeter
and the very point of this was that if
you are measuring time how do you know
that the the sample was run over a long
period of time in in a stable flow load
the the reason you know is because
you're collecting this histogram in the
top right-hand corner that I've cartoon
there and you would see this on a
histogram but you know if you collect
sample for let's say it takes you a long
time to run sample so we're running some
samples at the moment where we have to
collect a very large number of beads
well it's not a huge number twenty
thousand beads but in a very dilute
sample and the sample cannot for a
number of reasons be concentrated and so
it takes us about 15 or 20 minutes to
run each of these samples if you don't
run time as a parameter and the only
thing you do at the end of 20 minutes is
look at a histogram you're really not
going to know whether there was a small
blockage or some change in the
whirring so I really want to emphasize
this and from an educational perspective
that you really should be collecting a
time as a perimeter so let me move on to
the last section or the second last
section is it of what I want to talk
about and that is the side scanner and
for some reason or other beckman coulter
call this vs SC violet a side scatter i
guess is is what that means and let's
ask us a couple of questions about side
scatter what do we what do we know about
side scatter so some very basics is we
know that in general terms the larger
the difference in refractive index then
there will be more light scattered by a
particle we also know that the more
granular the particle is the probability
of getting light reflecting off those
sub components increases and that's why
you see in this diagram that I put in
the middle there where you see
granulocytes for example that had lots
of granules in them and a very different
arrangement of the nucleus these girls
are like sub components of the cell and
they scatter a large amount of light we
know that the amount of light scattered
by any particle is proportional to the
diameter of the particle and it's
inversely proportional to the wavelength
of light used to detect it so if we
lower the wavelength of the excitation
will see increased side scatter of any
given particle size so if you use say
488 nanometer excitation as opposed to
405 meter excitation you will get a
certain let's get a signal from each of
those lasers if you
move to a lower wavelength you will
actually increase the resolution of
small particles that can be detected now
we know that and several people have
published on this now we also know that
when you enter a medium of a different
refractive index and I've put a little
prism there that the light waves that
are reflected by this different
refractive index is inversely
proportional to the wavelength of the
light and with the lower wavelengths
having higher reflect refraction than
the larger weblinks and we can all thank
Isaac Newton for working that out for us
so if you now look at lower wavelength
let us say 40 5 nanometers instead of
488 you can see here some data collected
on the side effects we're really quite
small particles can be resolved and I'll
show you in a little while how easy that
is to do on the side effects but the
point that I want to make is that you
can actually measure side scatter
simultaneously from each of those lasers
in a very very simple way and because of
that and because of the ease of
measuring it this this I think is one of
the interesting advantages of the side
effects so let me now lastly talk about
the lasers and the configuration of the
the lasers on the side effects because
that certainly will impact how many
signals that you can measure and which
WDM modules you need to use in order to
collect these signals so there are at
the moment I understand five possible
lasers
that you can put on the side effects
although only four can be put on the
side effects at any one time and these
range from near-uv which is 375 through
to what people commonly call a violent
laser in 405 a blue laser at 488
yellow-green at 561 and in a red laser
and in the soda flex the red laser
that's used is a 638 nanometer laser so
here's one laser layout that you can
have on the side effects this one shows
the 405 at the front now this is at the
top of the side of lexan on the very
front normally this area on the left has
a cover over it so you can't actually
see this of course you don't want to
have lasers exposed so this is
completely covered but each of these
black blobs on the right hand side and
the one at the back where the red arrow
is are the actual lasers and on the top
right hand side you can see how the
lasers are let's say visualized into the
fiber optic collection fluorescence
collection that comes out of this system
this is a single fiber that collects all
of these these separated lasers so this
is one configuration there are several
different configurations so what I've
tried to show here is a different
configuration and and on this one I want
to come back to what I said about these
WDM modules and and how these WDM
modules can be applied so you can see on
the left here one WD a module has
several detectives and some some
bandpass filters up here the the middle
145 61 has the same sort of arrangement
but on the right hand side we have this
split w DM module you can see that two
lasers which they let's say not the
lasers the light coming from the
excitation of two different lasers is
coming into a split w DM and so that
where the red circle is is the WDM
module that is split now and a couple of
things you see here that there are some
blank spots here so so where I've got
two red arrows there is no signal going
to those detectors and what's
interesting here is that I can measure
the side scatter from two different
lasers and you can see on the green
arrows here I've I've got a side scatter
measurement from a 488 and over on the
left-hand side I've got a side scatter
measurement on on the 405 so that's
actually a very simple process I can
actually get a side scatter measurement
of any laser by simply putting the
appropriate band pass filter into any of
these WDM modules so it's a really neat
feature here's a slightly different
layout and you can see here that we've
split this 375 in the 638 lasers going
into to these WDM modules so there's a
basically i would say it will it's not
an infinite number because you have
limited number of lasers than alivelu
limited number of detectives but there's
a huge number of combinations that can
be made
in what I think is pretty clear is is
the simplest possible layout that you
can have for a laser system so I'm just
highlighting their the the detector that
is split and here I've again highlighted
that I can measure the side scatter from
two different lasers now I don't have to
I can put in one or other of these green
arrows any appropriate bandpass filter
there's really no limitation 22 which 22
which filters the only limitation of
course will be the bands that are
actually coming from that laser so I
just outlined here some of the types of
layouts that you can have and you can
see that changing a system is is very
simple now it is true that you're you're
going to have a fixed laser combination
or whatever instrument that you get but
but within that fixed laser layout you
have quite a large number of
possibilities and and on this slide for
example with the the 405 the 561 the 488
in the 638 laser I've listed there a lot
of the common dies that you can use so
this really is I think a very broad
spectrum number of dice you can use now
I think it's only recently that the 375
was added to the side effects I haven't
used the 375 myself but I know
oh that Milt Alfred and some others have
used the 375 and I'll show you some of
bills data in a moment but there are
some advantages to the 375 laser because
it may be even better at exciting some
of the these amazing brilliant violet
dyes that are now available and work
very well with the 405 laser and they
may well work even better with the 375
certainly the 375 has an advantage for
hoechst and dabby because it's even more
efficient and I'll show you some data in
a moment with side population but it's
actually fairly good and certainly a lot
cheaper alternative to trying to put a
true UV later in the 350 355 range and
another advantage of that is it doesn't
have any high thermal output and of
course you don't have to deal with the
other complications of the the the 350
355 lasers with power supplies and high
voltage and sheer size the other thing
is that basically it's as good as the
355 almost as good let me say as the 355
for most of these dyes obviously having
a perfect laser with the absolute right
flora crow is always better but it's
somewhat impractical to be able to do
that and in the field of flow cytometry
we are almost always compromising on the
laser line and the band pass and the
dike
works that we use to accommodate our our
essay design so these this data these
data excuse me are showing the 375 laser
exciting dappy and i think i have a
slide in a moment from from from bill
telford i think it's a few slides now
but i just to show you a couple of
slides that it is indeed possible
depending on the laser combination and
the WDM modules that you you establish
that you can produce excellent quality
multicolor data analysis and this is
showing some quilt 12 color analysis
using the UV true UV laser so there are
advantages and disadvantages with having
to set any combination of lasers but
I've highlighted here the yellow laser
and I'm just going to jump down a couple
of slides and I'll come back but the
reason i jump to this 561 is because
with dsred for example the 561 is really
gives a better signal than the 488 and
so that's really a reason for trying to
consider again depending on the sorts of
things that you're running as to why you
might select that yellow laser but
looking at the big picture of this
system taking the rainbow beads it's
pretty clear to me that this system has
a great deal of sensitivity and
a capable of giving excellent resolution
on those beads across every spectral
component that we're we're interested in
looking at and looking at particular
dyes that are of interest in in
hematology and clinical lab some of the
dyes that you see on here show excellent
resolution and sensitivity so I've
already shown this slide with deer
thread so jump past it but I did mention
that looking at hoechst and debbie has
some advantages so here is an example of
Herc's and happy with the the deep UV
laser and this is the site scatter
population that bill Telford did on the
side effects with the 375 nanometer
laser to show excellent side scatter
resolution and so that is what I would
consider to be a significant advantage
of being able to do the 375 nanometer
laser so what would be the take-home
messages so you might be a little
surprised at what I think the key
take-home messages are from the system I
don't think it's that the system is
using APD's or that the system users
wavelength division multiplexing or that
any of these things that i've shown you
are in themselves super special what i
think is super special about this is
that the combination of these components
the extreme linear
charity of these particular APD's the
way they are designed and the efficiency
of the wavelength division multiplexing
system and the efficiency of the light
collection which I really didn't discuss
because that is a unique feature of the
the side effects what I understand to be
something that's really unique is that
because of the linearity of this system
that this will change the way things
like compensation can be done and my
understanding of this is that because of
the extreme linearity that compensation
in this system can cross different
samples and different dyes and I think
that may be unique and that's not
something that has been discussed very
much if this is true then this changes
the way we deal with compensation
because what it means is that we may be
able to take a compensation library and
do mix and matching for for all of the
dyes that are run on a system and that
is something we don't consider in ennis
in most melissa thomas so that is the
end of my presentation and as I've said
here this opens up the potential of what
may be the holy grail of flow cytometry
that is a generation of instruments that
are completely self calibrated and are
able to do
this amazing matrice matrix of
compensation across a very broad range
of dyes and I guess that my opinion is
that the side effects may well be the
the beginning of a transformation in how
we do flow cytometry it's not just that
this is a tiny little box it's the
combination of these unique tools that
are inside this box that I found I find
extremely impressive and so with that
I'm going to turn over to duty to see if
there are any questions or any
discussion that that we are going to
have thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to run our audience how to submit
questions you can't submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
it as many questions as we can and
indeed many have come in so far our
first question is what has changed with
a VPS that has allowed them to work with
flow cytometry the question a Christian
decreased what has changed with APD's
that allows them to work with close to
torture you this is a great question um
like everything technology has evolved
you know I we we all have one of these
just go back 10 or 15 years and a
portable telephone was was a shoebox and
I had very little functionality um and
you can ask us well what changed to
allow that to happen
a lot of things change and the same is
true with a PDS the the structure the
size the efficiency of the design the
temperature control the noise control
the efficiency of getting the signal
into the APD all of those things have
changed so I would say that it's been an
evolution over many years of what has
actually changed in the APD that has
gotten us to this point where at least
one manufacturer and I guess originally
is I dejun took what might be considered
a risk of building a system with APD's
which I think has turned out to be a
quite a clever clever move so that's the
answer to my question it's a little bit
broad but a lot of changes over time why
is double DWDM more efficient like
collection okay so the question is why
is WDM more efficient um well I tried to
explain how clever WDM was in terms of
communication where you can send one or
two hundred phone conversations down an
optical fiber and dmax them that's
that's efficient one of the reasons why
the WDM system in the side effects is
efficient is because it it combines the
WDM concept with reflection optics and
in reflection optics you don't lose
signal
keep carrying the signal all the way so
you're not dropping you're not losing
much efficiency so instead of going
through dichroic after dichroic after
dichroic and then man pass you're really
only going through one bandpass filter
so that's one of the reasons why it's
more efficient and I'll hand back to
your duty thank you please explain why
pmts have a problem at 750 nanometers so
the question was please explain why pmts
have problems at 750 nanometers well
it's because of the materials that are
used in the elements of the PMT a PMT
works by a photon hitting and a material
that then emits photo emits electrons
and they multiply and depending upon
what that material is made of the
difference in the wavelength of the
photons that hits it will determine its
efficiency and it turns out that
penalties work up to about 800
nanometers quite effectively oh not
really effectively but they work ok up
to that wavelength they're obviously
much better at the wavelengths that we
use in for such luxury of say 450 to 650
or 700 nanometers but it's the
composition of the materials in the
photomultiplier tube that determine its
wavelength sensitivity and I'll hand it
back to you Judy
which type of APD is on site Oh flex sio
2 which wavelengths are detected in toe
side effects 300 up to eleven hundred
nanometers thanks Judy the question was
what is the nature of the APD's and I
would answer that if I knew but actually
I have no idea I suspect it's a
proprietary piece of information but I
personally do not know do you think of
using a PD for others cytometers
technology so the question was will will
will will others use APD's I guess it's
a matter of time there are a couple of
things that are advantageous about APD's
one of them is their costs they're there
a tenth the cost of a photomultiplier
tube so the more detectives you want on
a system mmm that should be an economic
advantage but it's tricky using APD's
you you have to change a lot of things
in how you build the system so not just
a matter of swapping out the PMT and
putting an APD in there that's not how
the side effects was designed so my
answer is I i would say that other
manufacturers would have to be looking
at this I'm certainly experimenting them
experimenting with them in my own lab so
that
I'm sure others will be doing the same
back to you Judy our APD sensitive to
temperature and if you yes do you think
that efficiency could be even better if
they are cooled down actively so the
question is I PD sensitive to
temperature and the answer is yes they
are and it is also true that cooling
them can improve them I don't know the
details about how a beckman manage or
manipulate their APD's in the system but
in general the questioner is correct
that temperature is usually does have an
impact on the noise level of an apt and
cooling is definitely an advantage back
to you GT is there a special limitation
for six APD by WD m
so the question is why are there six
APD's on the WDM I have absolutely no
idea but I'm going to make a guess so um
I would say that it's a matter of
physical size and design 6.the it's this
to some extent the bandpass filter which
is a few millimeters wide that's going
to give some restriction in how many the
second is how far apart the APD's can be
can be mounted my understanding um well
though haven't send them on the board
but my understanding is the APD's are
mounted on a circuit board and so
there's a physical distance between
APD's that you have to mount them the
APD sir oh I don't know five six
millimeters apart in size so I suspect
that for efficiency that that's the most
efficient way of mounting these and my
understanding is that there are three
banks of APD's on the motherboard and
that there are probably separated
physically as closely as an APD can be
made but that's my own personal guess
maybe someone at beckman coulter has a
more intelligent answer back to you duty
the next person says I run SSC in linear
mode but some others do it in log mode
please comment so the question is a side
scatter in linear mode and log mode well
this is a digital system so you you have
the the raw data you can you you you
have everything that you need you don't
need to to you can promote this too long
tater if you want and plot it but you
have all the raw data so that's the
answer to my question so the question
sorry you said you sing that you open a
slot on WDM do you know if we could
activate them it didn't get the question
could you get the question I didn't get
that question if you can repeat it
please you said open slot on WDM do you
know if we could activate them the
question was I mentioned an open slot on
the WDM and and can you activate them
maybe I didn't make myself clear what I
was saying is that I'd simply I showed a
slots where no band pass filters were
inserted so no signal no signal specific
signal will be detected on that so the
APD is still active they're there
they're not they're not there's no
requirement for them to be activated all
the APD's are available I was just
indicating that in those two slots where
those two green arrows were on that
figure that there was no band Pascal
is it back to you Judy did you try to
analyze more than 800 nanometer
wavelength on this APD and did you see a
particular benefit compared to PMT
insensitivity for example so the
question was did we go beyond 800
nanometers on the APD's and will it
therefore be more sensitive and the
answer to the first question is no I
have not personally done that but in
theory the answer is that it should be
because APD's are more sensitive up in
the red domain so I'll hand that back to
you with the answer it should be
absolutely with the incorporation of
sensitive APD's does this mean we're no
longer dependent on bright fluorescent
dyes so the question is if we have APD's
do we no longer dependent on right
versus ties kid and I would say we are
always going to be dependent upon bright
fluorescent dyes there's no real no real
easy answer to this question then except
that whatever you can do to increase the
efficiency of a system should be done so
I would never say just keep going to the
most inefficient dies I would also say
go to the most efficient die is always
the best model so don't depend on the
electronics of our technology improve
your essay use the best possible dies
that you can we know that the most
efficient way of a [ __ ] increasing
signal is by having a meta fluorochrome
it's it's not by having a more sensitive
technology more sensitive technologies
are great and are really important but
let's not throw away our bright eyes
okay let me know if you can answer this
one how is the dynamic range on the site
of flex compared to the after a actor I
so the question is what is the
difference in the dynamic range of the
side effects and the accurate I'm not
actually certain of the answer to this
but I do believe that the side effects
has a significant dynamic range I can
get that information and provide that to
the users or if it can be added to the
website later I'd be happy to identify
the correct technical answer for that
and I would go to a colleague in a
beckman coulter and get those details
and and provide that for the question of
compensation is also affected by natural
autofluorescence of biological samples
how is that library how will it deal
with it
so the question is a compensation can be
impacted by autofluorescence and and how
would the system that i mentioned deal
with that again i don't know the answer
to that it's going to be dependent on
some some testing what i was implying
was that if you have a system that is
highly linear and reproducibly linear
across different instruments that there
ought to be a major advantage in how we
deal with compensation and so i believe
that the autofluorescence always impacts
signals and there are other ways of
dealing with autofluorescence and as
many of you know i'm a proponent of
spectral hyper spectral analysis to deal
with order fluorescence that's a
completely different issue but it is one
mechanism for dealing with
autofluorescence so i guess is something
that will have to be tested to to see
what the results bring back to Eugenie
using using time as a parameter what do
you do if there's a blip in the
fluorescence you can always stop the
collection or throw out the sample
sorry about that delay but I was waiting
for getting control so the question was
using time as a parameter you can always
you'll always see it if you're running
it the real reason for collecting time
is you can always cut it out if it turns
out that there's a blip or a blockage
and it's a short period of time where
the where there's a blockage or
something else you can just go in and
get that out on your list mode file and
you you save which something that might
be a very valuable si so that's that's
one of the reasons that I suggest that
it should be on every system that if you
have an extremely valuable sense you
can't rerun it but and you may you may
be able to save that simple by getting
out at using time getting back to you
Judy have you checked the spillover
spreading matrix SSM and/or the
resolution impact matrix r IM on the
side flex there's a simple answer to
that and the answer is I have known you
talk about fitc comp of a thorough saito
flex did you try to do it now and
according to their respective bandpass
filters does it work well I haven't done
that across insurance so I can't
personally speak to it but it is the
goal of this technology to essentially
create a technology that is so
reproducible across instruments that
those comps can be
try and carried across so know the
answers I have not personally done this
but what I'm trying to explain is that
if you can design and build an
instrument that is let's say so
reproducibly designed and built so that
the detectors the Arctic's have
identical features identical parameters
then this is the this is what I think is
one of the big opportunities of the
technology we know that you just can't
do that on most instruments because
we're always fiddling with with with
knobs and where we're trying to
accommodate our sample to the instrument
taking one sample from one instrument to
another is is one of those difficult
things that we've struggled for years to
try to work out how to compare data from
one instrument to another so the point
that I'm trying to make is that I see
this is a possibility that this might be
the start of a new new way of doing
things in flow back to you GT okay the
next one is demystifying the WDM module
the term WDM leads to a lot of confusion
in my probably naive understanding there
is no real multiplexing or
demultiplexing in flow cytometers there
are no discrete laser lines to combine
or to divide like in telecommunication
networks or would you describe the
emission of different different
fluorochromes as multiplexing and the
special separation of fluorochromes as
demultiplexing then the boulevard galios
or the tod austria's would also be w
dams
so the question about WDS what I'm
trying to do is explain to you a
slightly different way of how the
technology is designed it is not exactly
the same as the communication industry I
was using that as an example of how
frequency changes are combined and then
separated again what we are talking
about on this instrument is a
combination of aspects that are WDM like
and utilize a more efficient way of
separating the signals that are coming
out of initially a single fiber and then
being divided into a number of what week
what cool what beckman coulter calls WDM
modules back to you GD ok we have time
for one last question and it is near UV
SSC would give even more resolution than
better than violet SSC so the question
is going down to the near-uv which is
described as the 375 nanometer line
would give you even better resolution
and in theory the answer is yes in
theory it would that's fairly simple
answer
I would like to once again thank dr. Jay
Paul Robinson for his presentation do
you have any final comments to Ferguson
I will think of Judy are the only
comments that I have are that it is a
lot of fun testing and using new
instruments and comparing them with
other instruments and i would say that
every instrument has its advantages and
disadvantages and what I've tried to do
on this is to to outline primarily the
advantages of this technology and I'd be
happy to answer questions from people
individually and I'll also point out
that very shortly will will be able to
provide a little more detail on some
solution ille videos that we've been
making that answer some of these
questions in slightly different way and
give you the opportunity of reviewing
these this material so thank you for
everybody for participating and I'm
happy to answer individual questions if
you you send them to me you can track me
down on the Purdue cytometry list well
Google me and I'm sure you can find me
thanks very much and good morning or is
it good afternoon good morning to people
in California or good afternoon to
everybody else thank you again i would
also like to thank our sponsor beckman
coulter life sciences for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through june fourth 2016 you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you in this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye